And the Lord said unto Abraham,
and this is,
this is the,
this is the opening of the story,
get thee out of thy country and from thy
kindred and from thy Father's House unto
a land that I will show thee.
And this is one of those phrases where
every clause is significant.
Go somewhere you don't understand.
That's the first thing.
Get the out of country.
You know,
back in the 19 twenties,
there was a whole slew of American
writers who ended up as expatriates in
Paris.
Hemingway among them,
who wrote the Great Gatsby,
Fitzgerald,
yes.
And then a variety of others.
It was very inexpensive in Paris at the
time and part of their transformation
into great literary figures was the fact
that they were out of their country and
now they could see what their country
was.
Because you can't see what your country
is until you leave it.
So you have to go into the unknown and
that's God's first command.
Go into the unknown because you already
know what you know and so,
and that's not enough.
Unless you think you're enough.
And if you're not enough and you don't
think you're enough,
then you have to go where you haven't
been.
And so that's the first commandment to
Abraham.
It's like,
okay,
that,
that's a good one.
That makes perfect sense.
Go to where you don't know.
Yes.
And from thy kindred will though,
does that mean it means grow up,
right?
That's what it means.
It means get away from your family
enough so that you can establish your
independence.
And that isn't because there's something
wrong with your family,
although perhaps there is,
you know,
as long as there is perhaps wrong with
you,
but it means get away.
You know,
I talked to people very frequently whose
families have provided them with too
much protection and they know it
themselves.
And that means they are deprived of
necessity.
You know,
one of the things that you see in,
in,
in the United States for example,
is that the children are first
generation immigrants often do better
than the children that their children.
And the reason for that is that the
children are first generation
immigrants,
have necessity driving them.
And you don't know how much you need
necessity to drive you because maybe
you're not very disciplined and if any
catastrophe doesn't immediately be fall
you.
If you don't act forthrightly today,
then maybe you never act forthrightly,
right?
Because the,
the gap between your foolishness and the
punishment is,
is lengthened by your unearned wealth.
And so you never grow up and learn and
you have to get yourself away from your
dependency in order to allow necessity
to drive you forward.
And that's to become independent and to
become mature.
And I think part of what's happening in
our culture is that the,
the,
the force that's attacking the
forthright movement forward of young men
in particular is afraid of the power of
man because it's confused about the
distinction between power and authority
and competence.
Like I know a man who's who has
authority and competence has power as a
byproduct,
but the authority and competence is
everything.
And,
and,
and people who can't,
that fail to make the distinction
between power and authority of
competence.
And they're afraid of power.
And so they destroy authority and
competence.
And that's a terrible thing because we
need authority and competence.
What else is going to,
what else is going to allow us to
prevail in the long run?
And so you get away from your country
and you get away from your kin and from
your father's house,
right?
And you go out there and you establish
yourself in the world.
It's a call to adventure.
That's what this first lines in the
Abrahamic story is a call to adventure.
So great unto a land that I will show
you.
Well,
you know,
what does that mean?
You know,
one of the things that I've been struck
very hard by a number of writers,
Carl Young,
obviously among them,
I mean he,
he wrote things like Nicha that if you
understand them,
they just break you into pieces.
You know.
And,
and one of the things that young
understood in the psychoanalysts
understand,
it's one of the most terrifying elements
of psychoanalytic thinking is very
tightly allied with religious thinking,
which is that you are not the master of
your own house.
There are spirits that dwell in you
within you,
meaning you have a will,
and you can exercise a certain amount of
conscious control over your being,
but there are all sorts of things that
occur within you that seem to be beyond
your capacity to control your dreams.
For example.
That's a really good example of your
impulses.
For example,
you might,
you might think of those as so foreign
from you that they're not even.
You don't even want them to be part of
you,
but,
but more subtly even.
How about what you're interested in?
What compels you?
Like,
where does that come from?
Exactly.
Because you can't,
you can't conjure it up of your own
accord,
you know?
So if you're a student and you're taking
difficult course,
you might say to yourself,
well,
I need to sit down and study for three
hours,
but then you sit down and that is what
happens.
Your attention goes everywhere.
And you might say,
well,
whose attention is it?
Then?
If it goes everywhere because you say
it's your attention,
it's like,
well,
hey,
if it's your attention,
maybe you'd be able to control it,
but you can't,
and so then you might think,
well jen and just exactly what the hell
is controlling it,
and you might say,
well,
it's random.
It's the better not be random.
I can tell you that that's.
That happens to some degree in
schizophrenia.
There's an element of randomness in
that.
It's not random.
It's driven by the action of of
phenomena that I think are best
considered as something like
subpersonalities.
They'll even.
That's only a partial description.
You can't make yourself interested in
something.
Interest manifests itself in grips you.
That's a whole different thing and so
what is it that's gripping you and how
do you conceptualize that?
Is that a divine power?
Well,
it's divine as far as you're concerned
because it grips you and you can't do
anything about it,
and so there is a calling in you towards
what you're compelled by and what you're
interested in,
and sometimes that might be very dark
and sometimes not,
but you're compelled forward by your
interest.
And so and so,
the idea that what moves you away from
your country and your father's house and
the comforts of your childhood home is,
is something that's beyond you and that
you listen to an Harken to.
That's exactly right.
And you can say,
well,
I don't want to call it that God.
It's like it doesn't matter what you
call it.
Exactly.
It doesn't matter to what it is,
what it's called.
It still is,
and if you don't listen to it,
that's the other thing.
If you don't listen to it,
and I've been a clinician and talked to
enough people now as old as I am,
to know this.
Absolutely,
if you do not listen to that thing that
beckons you forward,
you will pay for it like you cannot
possibly imagine.
You'll have everything that's terrible
about life in your life and nothing
about it that's good and worse.
You'll know that it was your fault and
that you squandered what you could have
had.